I need to provide two Starcraft
Chronicles okay one guy okay
we got in a convo about steroids okay I
didn't think anyone our age still played
like that
and so
based on my username
he like made a joke and then I joked
about being on roids and he said aren't
we all and then we kind of played and
then like
he just he won because I was just more
distracted typing and we just ended up
talking about trt for a while and then
he just left so like he gave me the win
okay
and what was he saying he's like um
I'm on a low dose now you know I'm on a
moderate level I used to be higher but
my wife this is the most he goes
my wife
said I was too irritable but little did
she know she was the reason LOL
wait this is all via chat yeah okay okay
and I was just like uh
all right okay what do you want me to do
with that yeah seriously and then
he just goes on about you know my dick
feels like it's 18 again until
it's like all right
that's sick man yeah
I think I just said for sure
what the hell do you want me to do with
them yes seriously okay what do you want
me to say to that yeah and so
you just love that LOL yeah and then he
what yeah yeah that's awesome dude can I
see yeah yeah he basically just ended it
saying yeah get on it and then just left
the game
maybe it was Derek yeah it's probably
Derek yeah and then um this other kid I
call him a kid because it was so funny
that these games were back to back it
was just a stark reaction
uh when someone does kind of like a
cheap move it's referred to as like
cheese yeah like uh you're cheesing okay
and so I I typed LOL I'm like man all
you guys do is this type of build which
is like very cheesy and I just left the
game
and then here's supposed to be here he
goes and all you do is lose like a [ __ ]
he's like cry more then he calls me the
r word and laughed I'm like damn dude
this game is so old I don't think
there's any teenagers on here and there
either that is just a man child that's a
full-on 16 year old just raging at me
cry more you [ __ ]
I was like wow you kind of got on there
a little bit I did but I was just
laughing like damn gaming is still alive
yes in Starcraft I thought it was like a
dead game yeah but
that spectrum of conversation oh this
game is it's thriving so why did you
leave because he was he was gonna win
yeah he cheesed me and I was just like
oh
couldn't let him win huh
not really yeah that's lame yeah yeah
it's just like this it was like people
do that to you though when you're about
to win
um no because I don't play like that I
don't chase people uh I see yeah it's
corny I see even when I win I I'll I
keep it up dude the forced internet
positivity man I love that and they they
reciprocate I love that now it's getting
more evolved
you know yeah and when guys beat me are
confident I'm like hey man that's a
great build I'm like this [ __ ] unit
that [ __ ] does damage like yeah dude
you're like you're [ __ ] you're like
you're building solid dude like you had
me like playing like you know it's it's
very like Dad yeah and your dick is like
[ __ ] 18 years old 18 years old again
dude that thing's pumping dude it must
be hard as a rock dog you know what I'm
gonna do yeah I'm gonna start with the
positivity yeah and see if I can just
take it into flirting and see if I get
them to flirt back yeah it's like dude
that build was sick thanks man yeah I've
been working on it yeah I bet you're
[ __ ] hung
whoa I thought it was gonna be a little
bit more subtle no no but you get in
just hard just like the build is sick
man really strong for a guy like you
yeah it makes sense that you do strong
builds yeah I could tell you LOL I can
tell you're good yeah I can tell your
dick is [ __ ] huge
no he reads that he's like
yeah yeah yeah
I bet yours is dude yeah it started
blushing yeah yeah yeah bro stop yeah
come on dude if I'm bigger yeah yeah
you're the one with the big dick dude
come on dude I could tell you just like
mine's small yours is the one that's big
I think one guy's trying to I think one
guy's trying to bone me why because I
beat him and I was like hey man I'm like
you did all right he's like thanks he he
was frantically adding me
and trying to add me to his friends list
and he's like Whispering me he's like
he's like dude your playstyle is like
perfect this is this is all via chat
it's chat okay he's like dude your play
style is perfect like I feel like we
should play together I'm like ah
he trying to [ __ ] you are trying to [ __ ]
so you got the internet positivity takes
a turn sometimes yeah yeah yeah
sometimes you can be a little too
positive I made that I made that guy
feel good yeah I made him feel something
yeah he's like ah [ __ ] I want to play
with this guy again I don't know why but
I really want to play with him let me
game with you bro
[Music]
I promise it's not weird it's just you
made me feel kind of cool I don't know
what I want with you yeah
yeah man
I'm getting a little too
I'm getting too in it though it's not
taking me long I'm back at it you should
stream it or something no no It's gotta
be for me no stream yourself flirting
with these dudes yo bro that actually is
a funny stream yeah what is up guys
we're on Starcraft today and we are
flirting we're trying to get yeah as
many dudes to add us as possible trying
to get as many compliments on our play
style every time they like try to engage
me I just like respond I'm like damn
smart
[ __ ] you got me breathing heavy over
here dude
damn dog you got me worked up slow down
just like yo what what's going on
why are you making it sexy
that's a hot ass play dude yeah
it's just got my heart pumping bro
he's like yo this rematch the rematch
like [ __ ] up butterflies right now
I've never felt like this while playing
this game before yeah I've never done
this before LOL
I swear I've never done this before LOL
go easy on me yeah
oh my God you are clapping me
[Laughter]
oh my God you are tearing my [ __ ] up
dude you own me
they just quit early because yeah yeah
that was kind of comfortable [ __ ] you're
owning me you're owning me you're only
me just over and over
it just started in the cyber sex dude
[ __ ] video
God you're so deep inside oh you're so
deep inside
you're in my base you're to the base we
play this game is so [ __ ] hot
you're to my base
because it's
there's something like they're like they
quit they're like dude stop yeah
you [ __ ] lose like a [ __ ]
cry more
like oh what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] dude
rematch me it's like yeah rematch me as
soon as you get back in the game would
love for you to rematch yeah no you
realize the first the first thing you
say as soon as you get in I bet you're
gonna [ __ ] my [ __ ] so hard
I bet you're gonna [ __ ] punish me
dude it's kind of a funny technique is
to go in and just be like super like I
bet you're gonna beat me so bad today
like super self-conscious
insecure yeah it's so insecure
I oh man I suck at this game law you're
probably gonna beat me so bad LOL
no seriously I hate myself
it's just like every time I play like I
just I feel like a piece of [ __ ] cause
like I'm so dumb I cannot figure it out
yeah yeah they're like dude come on yeah
you just destroy them damn law my first
one ever LOL yes [ __ ] maybe I'm pretty
good
damn you lost to me you're bad
you're like so bad I'm six yeah
that guy got me good yeah that is such a
good bit yeah that is really good I I
don't know I'm sick this is my first
game yeah
so
I just learned what colors are yesterday
I can count to flea and four and five
hahaha